c'est maintenant que nous allons agir
ensemble pour vérifier quelque chose
c'est dans quelques minutes que nous
allons éteindre ensemble les lumières
que nous avons laissés allumés
même quand elles ne sont pas
indispensables je vous ai demandé tout à
l'heure de laisser allumer les lumières
chez vous comme d'habitude et le moment
est venu de s'apprêter à les éteindre
et auparavant nous allons rejoindre
michel chevalet qui se trouve au centre
de distribution d'electricité de france
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure devant ses
cadrans et c'est avec lui que nous
allons regarder ses cadrans michel
chevalet à vous eh bien oui roger
gicquel vous voyez en ce moment comme
moi sur votre écran justement ce fameux
compteurs sur lequel va s'enregistrer
n'ont pas encore une fois la
consommation d'électricité des français
en ce moment mais la variation de
consommation donc et nous nous attendons
votre feu vert votre pouvoir
cette aiguille se déplacer dans ce sens
là c'est à dire que les français
consommeront moins ou autrement dit à ce
moment-là l'edf sera en surproduction
donc roger gicquel est bien nous
attendons votre top pour que
l'expérience des buts nous sommes prêts
à suivre les variations de la
consommation d'électricité des français
alors maintenant voilà ce n'est pas sans
une certaine émotion que vous la voyez
cette lumière oui voilà ce n'est pas
sans une certaine émotion que je vais
éteindre cette lumière et pour que ça
marche pour qu'on voit la consommation
d'électricité décembre à l'edf là où se
trouve michel chevalet il faut il faut
que vous fassiez le même geste que moi
surtout les interrupteurs que vous avez
laissée allumée depuis le début de ce
journal
toutes proportions gardées c'est que
ceux comme si nous étions dans une
voiture que nous n'avions pas conscience
de notre vitesse et si nous jetons un
coup d'oeil au compteur on s'aperçoit
qu'on est déjà 130 ou à 140
on lève le pied par prudence et là nous
allons tous s'éteindre en même temps
pour mesurer sur le cadran de l'edf
l'économie qu'on peut faire si vous êtes
prêts je le suis attention un deux trois
éteignons les lumières qui ne sont pas
indispensables
qu'est ce qu'on voit maintenant
bien à l'edf rangé je suis comme vous
vous regardez c'est très net l'aiguillât
dépasser le zéro c'est à dire les kylie
production consommation et commence à
grimper allègrement les milliers de
kilowatts mais milliers de kilowatts
d'économie je parle c'est à dire nous en
sommes pour le moment à 25 milliers de
kilowatts
voilà les lui continue de monter repart
là je dirais qu'on ne met pas le pied on
n'appuie pas sur l'accélérateur en
relève au contraire on lève le pied
nous en sommes maintenant à 50 milliers
de kilowatts et ce je vous le rappelle
c'est le bilan pour toute la france en
ce moment qu'est ce que ça représente
les milliers de kilos à des milliers de
kilomètres vous avez là les repart le
nom par milliers de kilowatts ici mais
on parle on mégawatts
si vous voulez quand on va atteindre à
peu près là nous en sommes nous avons
dépassé le sens nous sommes à 150
milliers de kilowatts et bien c'est
l'équivalent de la consommation d'une
ville comme nancy ou nice vous voyez que
ce n'est pas du tout du tout négligeable
et la douce je pense sosa yens nous
stabilisons oui en quelque sorte là
c'est la fluctuation en direct de la
consommation des français nous en sommes
arrivés à un peu plus de 105 ans presque
à 175 milliers de kilowatts d'économie
d'électricité avec notre opération
pardonnez moi cette question michel
chevalet c'est pas truqué tout ça je
vous entends pas j'ai une couture c'est
très important de ma question
le conteur que nous voyons là il n'est
pas truquée a surtout pas il n'était pas
question de traiter les compteurs je
vous ai donné une bonne et simple raison
c'est que en ce moment même les gens de
l'odf au dispatching doivent suivre
l'évolution de la consommation pour
adapter sans arrêt les besoins à la
demande
donc il n'est pas du tout question
qu'ils perdent les yeux sur le compteur
de vitesse et là je peux vous dire nous
sommes réellement en direct et
l'aiguillé s'est stabilisé à 175
milliers de kilowatts d'économie
d'énergie c'est-à-dire que l'on
économise donc l'équivalent
de la consommation d'une ville comme
nice ou nancy ce qui est loin d'être
négligeable ce que je voudrais rajouter
roger gicquel c'est que ceux-ci cette
opération donc est une réussite pour tf1
une réussite pour les français la salle
edf et la chance pour l'économie
d'énergie monsieur syrota et bien cette
opération si tous les ménages français
l'a réalisé tous les jours on
obtiendrait une économie bien sûr
beaucoup plus considérable il faudra à
peu près multiplié par trois ses
chiffres et à ce moment là on
obtiendrait bien l'équivalent de
l'énergie fournie par une centrale
thermique alors je vais vous donner
encore un chiffre qui va vous faire
rêver même c'est que une ampoule de 100
watts en moins chez vous et bien cela
fait pour l'année l'équivalent pour 4
millions de foyers français et bien ça
fait l'équivalent de la production d'une
centrale thermique c'est à dire rien
moins que 275 mille tonnes de fioul une
dernière précision enfin ce que l'on
fait avec les landes superflu ce que
vous avez fait ce soir il faut le faire
aussi avec d'autres appareils qui se
trouve chez vous donc on peut réaliser
des économies dans d'autres domaines que
l'électricité certainement françois de
closets
la morale de l'histoire c'est qu'un
tiers des français peuvent de toute
façon en éteignant leurs lumières
provoqué une chute de consommation
importante à l'edf c'est un peu comme si
la totalité des français atteignait une
seule ampoule michel chevalet de vienne
nous le dira nous voulions mettre
l'accent sur le gaspillage individuel de
l'électricité ce qui devait aussi ce qui
devrait aussi inciter des pouvoirs
publics les collectivités les communes
je ne sais pas les les
les collectivités industriels qui les
soirs bureau allumé à faire le même
geste que viennent de faire nos amis tf1
oui d'ailleurs vous en aurez une
application avec
comme vous le savez avec l'heure d'été
va entrer en vigueur au début du mois
prochain
ce qu'il faut tout de même bien dire
c'est que ce que nous avons fait ce soir
c'est une opération quelque sorte
halte au gaspillage et encore uniquement
gaspillage individuelle alors l'économie
d'énergie ce n'est pas seulement la fin
du gaspillage la fin du gaspillage c'est
facile ça ne coûte pas cher et ça
rapporte à chacun de l'argent pour un
peu de discipline mais il faut savoir
que 10 1985 la france a prévu
d'économiser chaque année l'équivalent
de 45 millions de tonnes de pétrole
alors 45 millions de tonnes de pétrole
c'est près de la moitié de notre
consommation actuelle de pétrole
alors ça bien sûr ça ne pourra pas se
faire seulement en mettant fin au
gaspillage
il faudra en plus changé nous usine
changer nos fours changer nos
automobiles et cetera donc faire des
investissements très coûteux
il faudra produire des économies
d'énergie donc en un premier temps parce
que c'est raisonnable on arrête le
gaspillage en un second temps il faudra
investir pour les économies d'énergie